salut comment ça va aujourd'hui je vais
vous parler de smartphone je vous parle
de smartphone gaming je parle de
smartphone vraiment orienté gaming mais
qui sont surtout très bon en performance
alors je sais pas si vous connaissez la
marque coco la marque poco c'est une
marque intéressante et surtout qui
propose des smartphones super cool avec
beaucoup de performances et je pense
réellement orienter gaming paste en
photo mais beaucoup gaming et pourquoi
m'a dit tiens mon beau monsieur gros
est-ce que tu voudrais pas
dire que smartphone à savoir le poco F5
ici et son grand frère le poco est-ce
qu'on pro c'est donc aujourd'hui une
vidéo qui est réalisée en partenariat
avec poco pour vous présenter les deux
nouveaux modèles de la gamme très
intéressant performant vous allez voir
je vous dis tout dans quelques
[Musique]
alors pourquoi pourquoi pourquoi est-ce
que vous connaissez la marque coco en
fait poco a grandi avec Xiaomi
aujourd'hui une marque est totalement
indépendante bon ils vont juste garder
les ressources de Xiaomi pour la prod et
pour le SAV mais sinon il bosse tout
seul comme des grands leur objectif
c'est de vous proposer des smartphones
avec beaucoup de performances comme
n'importe quel smartphone haut de gamme
mais ici avec un excellent rapport
qualité-prix tout est maîtrisé en gros
leur slogan c'est tout d'un grand sauf
les prix bon ok sans l'aura compris et
là ils viennent de présenter deux
nouveaux smartphones le F5 et le F5 pro
alors vous en douterez le F5 pro enfin
un peu plus que F5 mais dans les deux
cas là de smartphones super alléchants
vous allez voir très maîtriser au niveau
des tarifs mais ça je vous dis tout à la
fin de la vidéo avec des offres
intéressantes donc attendez vraiment la
fin de la vidéo pour tout savoir sur
tout ce qu'on va faire ce qu'on vient
faire le tour complet de tes smartphones
ça joue tout vous dire qu'ils sont dans
le ventre et vous allez oh ça c'est cool
alors regardez on dégage ça et on emmène
les smartphones coucou les lapins alors
vous allez avoir deux smartphones qui
sont un peu différents au niveau du
design ça c'est le poco F5 alors il
prend un peu les traces de doigts ça
vous allez le voir le pourquoi F qu'il
est assez marrant il y a un espèce de
faux effet carbone que je trouve assez
joli là vous voyez là on a trois
optiques je vais vous expliquer dans
quelques instants un grand écran à
l'avant qui est très cool qui est joli
qui est sympathique et là vous avez son
grand frère le modèle Pro qui lui par
contre c'est liseré carbone sur le haut
et sur le bas mais n'a rien juste ici
donc là on peut se regarder c'est un
petit miroir coucou vous avez un bloc
photo qui est légèrement différent mais
vous avez exactement la même
configuration les mêmes optiques il y a
une petite différence de poids 180 g
pour le F5 et 2004 g pour le modèle Pro
bon voilà ça change globalement pas
grand chose mais il y en a un qui sera
un poil plus lourd que l'autre alors le
F5 sera disponible en blanc bleu ou noir
bon moi j'ai petit carbone noir comme ça
qui est très joli tandis que le modèle
Pro est dispo en blanc et en noir et ce
qui est intéressant c'est qu'ils nous
ont mis un Corning Aurier à glace 5 à
l'avant d'un côté l'autre pour bien le
protéger alors justement cet écran
parlons-en on va avoir exactement
justement la même diagonale d'écran quel
que soit le smartphone
6,67 pouces c'est très grand c'est
surtout une dalle un mollet alors le
fait d'avoir une dalle à molette ça a
plusieurs intérêts premier intérêt
d'avoir cette dalle AMOLED et bien c'est
que tout ce qui va être pixel noir et
bien c'est un pixel éteint donc ça
permet d'économiser la batterie du
smartphone par exemple si je passe en
mode sombre tout ce qui est noir vous
voyez un peu partout et bien c'était
éteint donc ça devient pas consommer
donc si vous voulez finir économiser la
batterie de votre smartphone passer en
mode sombre sinon vous pouvez rester en
mode claire dans les deux cas vous avez
des diagonales d'écran qui vont jusqu'à
120 Hertz d'actualisation vous allez ici
vous laissez soit par défaut il va
falloir directement de 60 heures jusqu'à
120 Hertz en fonction de besoin que vous
aurez un instant T par rapport aux
applications vous allez venir utiliser
soit vous pouvez venir le personnaliser
vous lui dites tout le temps tu es en 60
et en 120 je vous recommande vraiment de
venir par défaut comme ça il fait tard
tout seul donc ça c'est d'un côté de
l'autre ça c'est bien la différence que
vous allez avoir entre les deux modèles
c'est que le F5 va avoir une résolution
Full HD tandis que sur le modèle Pro
vous êtes en wqhd plus donc vous allez
avoir davantage de pixels une meilleure
résolution c'est pas mal alors autre
honnêtement déjà le F5 comme il est là
est très agréable et convient
parfaitement bien après ça va dépendre
une fois de plus des envies de chacun et
il y a aussi une petite différence
également c'est le taux
d'échantillonnage tactile en fait ça va
être la sensibilité quand vous allez
lire toucher à l'écran et quand vous
allez venir jouer le F5 va jusqu'à 240
Hertz tandis que le F5 pro va jusqu'à
480 Hertz on a deux fois plus vous voyez
on est vraiment orienté gaming ici et
aussi une autre techno qui est
intéressant c'est pour lutter contre la
fatigue oculaire lorsque vous allez
venir utiliser votre smartphone donc on
est sûr de faible luminosité et bien ce
qui est bien ici c'est que vous avez
1920 Hertz de PWM timing alors derrière
ce nom un petit peu barbare ça veut dire
quoi ça veut dire que lorsque c'est dans
conditions de faible luminosité il y a
votre smartphone va lutter
automatiquement contre la fatigue
oculaire en vous mettant cette fréquence
de 1920 Hertz voilà un peu le principe
en gros ce qui faut retenir c'est que
lorsque vous avez pas beaucoup de
lumière et bien vos yeux vont pas être
crevés et ça c'est cool autre truc qui
est intéressant
c'est que smartphone vous
avez bien le 3 Bluetooth 5.3 dans les
deux cas Dolby Atmos dans les deux cas
il y a une petite différence au niveau
de l'audio c'est que sur le F5 et bien
vous avez une prise jack donc vous
pouvez venir vous brancher directement
avec un petit casque en prise jack si
vous le souhaitez et puis surtout il y a
une petite différence au niveau de la
qualité audio je préférais légèrement la
qualité audio du F5 pro par rapport au
F5 qui sera un peu meilleur alors
c'était pas à vous en rendre compte
comme ça là on est sur le F5 vous voyez
on sera un peu plus sur le médium sur le
F5 que sur le S5 pro qui revient un peu
plus de grave
[Musique]
et de l'autre autre point de détail sur
l'un ou sur l'autre vous avez
vous avez une batterie de 5000
milliampères heure c'est grand c'est
très grand et c'est très bien tandis que
sur le F5 Pro vous avez une batterie de
5160 millions par heure un poil plus
gros un poil mais surtout ce qui nous
intéresse c'est que à l'intérieur de
chaque boîte est bien vous avez votre
bloc de charge qui est inclus donc ça
c'est sur le F5 g mon chargeur 67 watts
donc ça c'est cool et si j'ouvre mon F5
pro et bien je me retrouve avec
également un bloc de charge 67 watts
donc dans un cas et dans l'autre j'ai de
la recharge rapide j'ai les câbles
fournis j'ai tout ce qu'il faut à
l'intérieur de la boîte donc ça c'est
quand même très cool et très rassurant
tout en sachant qu'en plus ici c'est
deux smartphones sont compatibles charge
sans fil 30 watts et que vous le
cherchez jusqu'à 50% seulement un quart
d'heure en filaire très facilement
tandis que vous le recharger sans fil
jusqu'à 50 % en 32 minutes donc c'est
également très rapide donc en fait on
voit que déjà le fait d'avoir un écran
AMOLED si vous activez le thème sombre
et bien vous allez gagner en termes
d'autonomie en plus si les Français
sortent Qualcom que vous avez dans un
smartphone et dans l'autre sont pas
particulièrement énergivores on sera
très bon vous avez en plus des grosses
batteries vous avez de la charge rapide
donc il tout ce qu'il faut pour avoir
une autonomie qui vous emmène à au moins
un jour et demi sans problème alors
après attendez calmez-vous si vous jouez
énormément toute la journée à des jeux
la journée vous l'aurez pas mais si vous
en avez un usage normal et modéré vous
pouvez le garder un jour et demi et ça
c'est bien et au-delà de ça si vous
l'utilisez beaucoup et vous mourinez à
fond vous le recharger rapidement donc
une fois de plus vous n'aurez aucun
problème ici alors il y a un autre sujet
que je conseille de regarder bien
évidemment c'est la partie photo alors
vous le voyez c'est la même chose en
fait d'un côté et de l'autre vous avez
un grand angle de 64 mégapixels qui va
être stabilisé optiquement un ultra
grand-angle de 8 mégapixels et une
caméra macro de 2 mégapixels sans
oublier une caméra de selfie qui est
planqué juste ici de 16 mégapixels c'est
exactement la même configuration sur le
F5 et sur le F5 pro alors je vous le dis
autant ces smartphones sont très bons en
performance sont en termes de photos
c'est pas forcément là où ils vont être
les meilleurs si vous regardez le grand
angle bon globalement le rendu est pas
mauvais on peut venir faire des photos
shooter quelques souvenirs mais vous
allez voir que au niveau des hautes
lumières c'est pas forcément ça si on
passe sur l'ultra grand-angle bon il
nous sort aussi des choses c'est pas
dégueu pour des souvenirs mais ça va
manquer un petit peu de piquer et c'est
pas foufou on peut venir zoomer en X 2
en X 5 jusqu'à une fois de plus évitez
de venir jusqu’en faut 10 parce que de
toute façon c'est un zoom numérique donc
ça viendra dégrader la qualité de la
photo voyez ici bon on peut sortir
quelques souvenirs grand angle ultra
grand-angle et venir se rapprocher
shooter quelques petites fleurs si on le
souhaite des paysages la macro bon la
macro je suis jamais bien satisfait on
est sur une caméra de mégapixel c'est de
toute façon pas terrible compliqué de
trouver la bonne distance et puis les
photos sont un peu terne mais ça une
fois de plus sur une caméra de mégapixel
sur un smartphone comme celui-là on se
doutera que la macro ne sera pas géniale
ensuite on peut continuer grand-angle
ultra grand-angle tu es l'objectif vous
voyez ici globalement la photo c'est pas
son avantage c'est pas là où il va être
le meilleur la caméra de selfie je
trouve aussi un petit peu terne et pas
folle folle même si vous arrivez à
sortir des choses globalement c'est
smartphone sont sympas sont vraiment
orientés performance et autant vous avez
énormément de performances autant la
photo ça sera quand même en dessous
alors après si vous souhaitez pouvez
venir filmer en 4K sur les deux
smartphones et jusqu'en 8k ouais
jusqu'en 8k sur le modèle professionnel
je ne suis globalement pas convaincu
qu'il faille venir faire de la vidéo et
que ces smartphones mais si vous voulez
le faire vous pouvez le faire avec ici
une stabilisation optique bien
évidemment et électronique alors ces
smartphones ils ont tous les deux une
double sim 5G tous les deux une
certification
ip53 résistant à l'eau et à la poussière
alors on évite de les jeter dans la
flotte bien évidemment mais s'il croise
de l'eau ça va aller ils ont tous les
deux de l'infrarouge ça c'est aussi
sympa donc si vous voulez venir utiliser
votre smartphone comme une télécommande
et bien on peut le faire avec de
l'infrarouge et ils ont tous les deux du
NFC pour le paiement des matérialisés
autant dire qu'ils ont toutes les
dernières techno qui conv pour ce
typologie de smartphone dans cette gamme
de prix et les prix on en parle dans
quelques instants donc ils sont hyper
performants ils sont endurants ils s'en
chargent rapidement avec un bloc de
charge inclus vous avez de très beaux
écrans à molette ici bref c'est un bon
combo pour des smartphones qui sont pour
moi en tout cas réellement orientés
gaming même si on peut les utiliser pour
pas d'autres choses pour les réseaux
sociaux pour les emails bien évidemment
pour regarder des films des séries pour
se divertir et on peut même faire
quelques photos si on veut alors je
récompense de la douloureuse les tarifs
vous allez voir que la douloureuse elle
est pas si douloureuse que ça en fait
vous avez deux smartphones vous l'avez
bien compris vous avez votre F5 qui est
là et vous avez votre F5 pro qui est là
ok pour le F5 vous avez deux config 8 +
256 ou 12 + 256 normalement il coûte 429
celui-là 90 je vous enlève les virgules
et lui il coûte 479 ça c'est les tarifs
de base je dois les tarifs intéressants
dans quelques instants pour le F5 Pro
vous avez trois configs 8 + 256 12 + 256
et vous avez également une version 12 +
512 pour les plus énervés normalement le
tarif c'est 5
629 et 649 je vous passe bien évidemment
les virgules 90 que vous retrouvez un
petit peu partout sauf que vous avez une
offre qui est intéressante jusqu'au 16
mai et uniquement jusqu'au 16 mai ce qui
vous permet d'avoir votre F5 en version
12 256 non pas à 479 mais à 429 €. donc
ça vous sort en fait la configuration en
12 au tarif du 8 ça c'est vachement bien
et en plus de ça pour votre F5 pourquoi
vous offre une poco watch ça vous permet
donc d'avoir votre montre connectée qui
est offerte et qui elle coûte quand même
89,99 €. donc ça c'est cadeau donc si
vous voulez acheter le F5 et si il vous
fait de l'oeil et bien vous avez votre
config en 12 giga de ram au tarif du 8
giga de ram plus une montre poko watch
offerte ça c'est très très bien et alors
si on vient regarder pour le modèle Pro
il y a aussi des offres qui sont
intéressantes vous avez moins 50 euros
sur tous les smartphones la version 8
256 ça vaut la sorte donc non pas à 579
mais à 529 euros c'est cool celle-ci il
a la 12 + 256 ça vous le sort pas à 629
mais à 579 donc en gros ça vous sort ici
de la même manière le 12 au tarif du 8
et le 12 + 512 ça vous le sort pas à 649
mais à 599 €. et en plus de ces 50 € de
remise que vous avez partout il vous
offre 150 euros à 200 euros de bonus
reprise sur votre ancien smartphone
uniquement sur me.com d'ailleurs je vous
mets les liens juste en bas dans la
description valable sur les iPhone les
Samsung les Huawei et les possesseurs de
poco F4 GT pour remercier leurs bons
clients donc autant vous dire que ici et
ça c'est uniquement jusqu'au 16 mai et
bien vous avez
des souvenirs achetés soit votre poco L5
soit votre poco L5 pro elle est
meilleures conditions voilà c'est pour
moi c'est cadeau donc vous voyez deux
smartphones qui sont très cool très
orientés performants très orientés
puissances brute avec une grosse
batterie avec des blocs de charge avec
des design hyper canon tout ça pour
venir vous faire plaisir donc voilà
c'est beau c'est poco donc dites-moi
vous ce que vous en pensez dans les
commentaires si vous intéresse bien
évidemment je vous mets un lien dans la
description et on se retrouve très
bientôt pour continuer à parler tech de
smartphone mais pas que bisous à bientôt
et ou prenez soin de vous Ciao
[Musique]